Muraki no so two Brazilians it is defeat
catastrophe disaster the Marikana so was
the World Cup final Brazil lost to urgh
why back in 1950 on its own turf the
last time the event was held on
Brazilian soil
the Maracana americano so is the stadium
where the tragedy took place it was
built in Rio de Janeiro just for the cup
and is still the biggest stadium in
South America and this year's final will
yet again be won and lost on the
Moroccan as pitch the AH so in maracanã
so adds the umph in Portuguese in
Spanish you add assets any noun to make
it great like Galasso or amigas o or to
mean that noun is delivering a blow like
code ah so an elbow to the face or
cabeza so a headbutt so Moroccan also
means brazil's whopping spirit killing
still haunting epic upset at the
Maracana stadium in 1950 what happened
it was July 16th and it was all going
according to plan
Brazil at breeze past Sweden and Spain
with their famed beautiful game arrghh y
also known as the Celestia was the
country that had won the first Cup ever
in 1930 but this time it had barely
squeaked through earlier rounds and was
a clear underdog in the final all Brazil
needed was a draw and the cup would be
theirs as far as people in the country
were concerned their team at our d1
newspapers had triumphant headlines
waiting for the presses and FIFA had
even prepared a congratulatory speech
for Brazil and then the unthinkable
happened
the game is scoreless in the first half
two minutes into the second half Brazil
striker free ASSA guides a ball into the
ERG line goal - Cheers of ecstasy but
urgh why refuses to roll over the 66th
minute off the corner kick her wise ones
caffeine Oh blast the goal into the roof
of the net but at 1:1 the cup is sill
Brazil's then 11 minutes before the
final whistle 23 year-old Uruguayan
winger Alcides ghiggia sails the ball
just past Brazilian goalkeeper barbosa's
outside club and with that the celestia
wins two to one
200,000 Brazilians fall silent it's been
said the three fans have instant heart
attacks and at least one commits suicide
inside the stadium later Brazil football
legend Pele would say it was the first
time he ever saw his father cry it's
taken 64 years for the World Cup to come
back to Brazil sixty-four years for a
shot at scoring a winning goal a so at
the Marikana to this day Brazilians
don't like to remember the Moroccan also
but if they have their way in this World
Cup they might be able to forget
you